Hello everybody!
Hello!
Oh my god, I'm here.
I'm tired, but I'm here.
I need to check down some gamer subs, by the way.
Before this, before this matter.
As you guys know, the schedule is really messed up at the moment because I had that 3.30am tournament and I took that 2 hour nap and then I had the meet and greet and then I walked out and now I'm here.
What a day.
What a freaking day.
But I'm happy to be here!
I'm always happy to meet my dragoons here all the way from Florida.
That's where I can go.
Never been to Florida.
All I know about Florida is that it's America's dick.
That's really all I know.
And you guys have alligators.
And there's Florida man.
That's all I know about Florida.
But I'm so happy to be here.
I believe this is a Q&A.
I am so professional.
I was like, I think it's a Q&A.
But yeah, for those who don't know who I am, my name is Doki Bade.
I am a Vtuber.
I guess that's it.
I don't know what else to say.
I do not belong to any company.
I'm just an independent Vtuber.
Obviously I like to play.
I have a crippling addiction to Marble Rivals.
And I know that's a problem.
Right after this panel, I'm going to play Marble Rivals.
That's where I'm at right now.
Wish I was sponsored by Marble Rivals to show that game.
But I'm not.
I just have a very, very unhealthy addiction right now.
Anyway, I think that's really it.
I like to play shooters.
I was going to say FPS games.
But I was like, no.
Marble Rivals is third person.
I like to play games that go pew pew.
And oh my gosh, that's really it.
I laugh way too much.
But at that point, I feel like a lot of you guys are already like Stockholm Syndrome to my laugh.
That's basically like breathing now.
If she stops laughing, she'll die type deal.
Anyway, I don't really know how the Q&A portion is supposed to work.
So I assume like...
I don't know where the guy is with the microphone.
Where's the microphone?
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
I see the microphone.
There's the guy waving the mic.
So basically, I guess you raise your hand if you want to ask me a question.
And then like the microphone guy is going to come over and give you the mic.
And then I guess I answer your question.
That's basically it.
A lot of these panels are ready.
It's like second nature.
I'm hosting myself.
I'm my own MC too for my own panel.
So like I hope everything goes well.
I assume the guy with the microphone is going to screen the questions for me.
So nothing... so you know.
Yeah, things won't go like weird and awkward in the middle of this Q&A.
So I guess if you want to ask me a question, just raise your hand like you're in class.
And I'll be like you there.
You get the Q&A question.
Alright, who wants to ask me a question?
Nope.
Oh, okay.
No, everyone.
Wow.
Hi Doki.
I was wondering if maybe you have any tips for Marvel rivals.
Thank you for feeding my addiction.
Okay.
Well, okay.
So like this is something I learned yesterday.
So like yesterday I learned this out.
But when you get to Diamond, you can ban characters that other people pick.
So don't ban somebody's one trick because people get very mad.
And it's not... you know you think everything will be majority vote.
Because you know, literally five people banned Psylocke.
And then we had a Groot one trick.
And I was like wouldn't it be fun...
And we were all like laughing at that Groot one trick.
And we were like, wow, you can't play any other character wearing Grandmaster.
And then I was like, you guys, you know what's funny?
What if I vote for Groot to ban Groot?
And then I was literally the one person that voted Groot.
Apparently it's not majority vote for some fucking reason.
And it flipped to Groot.
Literally it was five Psylocke, one Groot, and it chose Groot.
And we had a Groot one trick.
We had two Groot one tricks actually.
That's the one thing I didn't say on the tweet.
We actually had two Groot one tricks.
So we were messed up at the beginning anyway.
And then my entire team was like, how dare you do that?
I was like, how was I supposed to know it was gonna flip?
Sorry, I'm sorry, I'm ranting right now.
I needed to let this out.
Anyway, don't ban people's one tricks because realize that it is not majority vote.
And banning a character is based off of random chance.
It doesn't matter who you vote for.
Voting doesn't matter in Marvel Rivals.
It's all random.
Anyway, another tip is that...
Another tip, I guess I play support.
I don't play DPS or tank.
Don't pee a one trick.
That's my other tip.
Don't pee a freaking one trick.
Because they will target you.
Anyway, I guess for support, just heal.
Who cares about the DPS?
Just heal the tanks.
No one cares about them.
They can yell at you all they want, but they're useless.
The tanks are what carries the game if you're a support player.
Anyway, that's my tip of the day.
Another helpful tip for Marvel Rivals is to not play Marvel Rivals.
Because it is... oh my gosh, I'm a mess.
It's a very unhealthy addiction.
I told this story before on stream.
Basically, I did a 15 hour session of Marvel Rivals.
And then after I was done, I had to go to the passport office to renew my passport.
Because it literally expired the next day.
And I didn't take a picture of it yet.
So then I went to a place to take a photo of your passport.
And I chose the 10 year option too.
Because I didn't want to do this again in 5 years.
I was like, 5 to 10 years.
I don't want to handle responsibility in 5 years.
I'd rather just wait 10 years.
So basically, I just went and took the picture post-ranking session.
The Marvel Rivals picture.
And they were like, is this the photo that you want to represent you for the next 10 years?
And I looked dead inside.
And in my head, I was like, yeah, that's the photo I want to represent me for 10 years.
So if you haven't tried Marvel Rivals yet, do not try Marvel Rivals.
Because it's not healthy for you.
It's not good for you.
It's a great game, but it's not healthy.
Alright, next question.
Who's the guy that's asking me the next question?
Alright, it's time to divide people.
Pizza or pasta?
Okay.
Oh, no, pasta.
100% pasta.
Pasta, there's so many different types of pasta you can get.
There's mac and cheese, there's linguine, there's fettuccine, there's penne, there's the others.
There's rigatoni, there's oh my god, there's so many pasta.
Pizza is just pizza.
It's just pizza.
To be fair, my favorite pizza currently is the hot honey pepperoni pizza.
That shit's fire.
If you've never tried it, it's actually so good.
But if you're really bad with spice, I guess it sucks to be you.
I'm sorry.
You're missing out.
100% pasta.
Alright, next question.
How does that divide people?
I don't understand.
It's like pizza and pasta.
They're both good types of food.
Hi, my question is, if you could cosplay any character, who would you want to cosplay?
Myself.
I love you so, I'm honestly, yeah, myself.
Oh my gosh, people who cosplay as me, in any form, like my current skin suit, shout out to you guys.
Especially during the summer, because I found out recently that leather jackets are incredibly hot.
So, shout out to you guys that are willing to wear a leather jacket during the summer, because that shit's hot.
But yeah, that's my answer.
Oh my gosh, it's like we're speed running.
It's just like that 30 second meet and greet again.
I'm sorry, I'm in that meet and greet mood right now, where it was like 30 seconds.
So like, I was like, it sucks to, like, okay, so like, I didn't realize it was 30 seconds.
I'm sorry to the first person I talked to during that meet and greet, because I didn't realize it was 30 seconds.
So I literally took up 20 seconds of just talking to them.
And then they're like, 10 seconds left.
I'm like, oh, I'm sorry, you didn't say anything.
Alright, next question.
Hi Doki, do you have any plans to do any more 3D?
Maybe like in your own setting instead of like a concert?
Oh, yes, 100%.
I have.
I've not prepped anything for it.
A lot of people think I did, but I have not.
I just got the model and everything.
But 100% yes.
I'm not currently, I know like Min has used her like 3D for the fireworks thing.
But like, I have no plans on using it, using the model yet for like home 3D stuff.
Because I want to like have an official debut debut for the model before I do like, before I use it in stream and stuff.
But like, the hardest part is just like, trying to, I guess like, I could use the studio where we did the, the concert.
But like, I do I want like, I'm like, because like, I'm thinking like, Oh, which studio should I get to do it?
Because I have like huge plans I want to do for my 3D debut.
And like, I want to like commission a bunch of like stages and stuff like that and have games and stuff.
And invite people to debut and everything.
So like, definitely not in the near future, near near future.
Maybe like, I don't know if you guys know this, but 3D is a lot of plans.
So it's a lot of work.
So like, I definitely want to do it, but it's not in the near future right now.
Because I have not even contacted any studios on like, you know, the filming wise of a 3D debut.
So yeah, we'll see how it goes.
We'll see how it goes.
I have like a million things happening right now.
I'm surprised like, I'm, I'm surprised I can, I can even function at the moment.
Yeah, that's my answer.
Hi Toki.
Hey.
I have a question.
Would you eat a hard boiled ragu egg?
Okay, but like, is there a dragoon inside that egg?
That's like, I mean, there's extra protein to be fair.
But, oh my god, it's literally just chicken.
Like, it's not, you're like, what?
That's, that's messed.
Sometimes I don't know if I'm allowed to swear because I'm pretty sure there's like kids walking around.
So, so I'm like, okay, thank you.
Like, maybe they're not sitting in the audience, but I'm pretty sure there's children walking around with their parents right now.
And I'm like being blasted out into the stage.
So I'm trying to make sure not to swear at the moment.
I'm sorry to the random kids that are parents, kids and family that's walking around.
I'm really sorry.
But I'm like thinking like, I mean, it's like, it's literally chicken.
So it's not that messed up to eat like a hard boiled egg.
I mean, we eat regular chicken eggs.
So like, what's that?
What's wrong with eating a dragoon egg when it's literally just chicken?
So yes, I would like it's not cannibalism because I'm not, I don't share the same biology as you.
I'm literally at the top of the food chain and you're at the bottom.
Next question.
Hello.
So I have a question.
If you could eliminate one entire video game franchise, like just completely erase it, what would it be?
League.
It's where toxicity began.
100% League of Legends.
I don't care what you guys say.
No, fuck MOBAs.
And you're like, no, not League.
You only like League because of Arcane.
I am, I, I've never, I played League one time, like 10 plus years ago.
And that was enough League to last me for eternity until I die.
So honestly, like, I don't even need to explain myself why I would eliminate League of Legends.
Like, I feel like it, like, if a video game that relies on team play removes one of the most crucial elements of team play, which is voice chat, then you know something is wrong.
If you can't even communicate with people in voice on a team game in ranked, something is fricking wrong.
Alright,
next question.
So Doki, remember the last song of the concert?
And how apparently it's supposed to be in front of the thing?
Oh, don't you shake it?
No, the one with the S word in it.
Oh, you mean, oh, you can't say it because there's children around.
Yes, yes, yes.
So, I, we talked to Mint yesterday, and apparently everyone who sang that song also had S.
What?
Yeah.
Wow, she said that.
That's new information to me.
So, does it mean that, what does it mean, make the dragoons and wisp?
What is that?
Wait, what does that make the dragoon or wisp?
What do you mean by that?
And the entire concert, does it mean that it starts with an O?
What?
Oh, I mean, you gotta make children so you can size kids to subscribe to me, right?
How else am I going to get some million subscribers, guys?
We need more children.
Okay, no, we don't need more children to subscribe because that's illegal.
I don't want to be marked as a kids channel.
We need more 13 and up users to subscribe to my channel because at best I'm at least PG-13.
Yeah, how else will we get more subscribers, guys?
That's the way I'll answer that.
I will not explain further.
Hello?
Hey!
Hey, who is the tomato cowboy here to challenge?
Oh, that guy?
He doesn't matter.
That's my meal for tomorrow.
Hello, this is a Doki bird panel, not some random tomato in the background.
Hello?
There we go.
Now you don't need to look at him anymore.
I'm not centered.
This is going to piss me off.
Never mind.
I'm not centered.
So, you always tell us to get up and move around all the time, right?
The question is, how much do you get up and move around in your time?
I literally went to Atlanta.
That is the most giddy...
I did a concert, bro.
I danced.
I touched grass.
No, did I actually touch grass?
Oh my god, no.
I have a dog.
I have to walk that... Oh, sorry.
I have to walk that freak.
Okay, I'm sorry.
He's not a freak.
I love my dog.
I have to walk him at least twice a day.
So I do get up and move around.
Check, how much do you move?
Oh, you're at a convention, so you're literally outside right now.
Yes, I do touch grass.
I literally physically have to touch grass so that my dog will poop on the grass.
I understand that getting a new outfit takes months, sometimes years, depending on certain things.
Is there any oddball, throw-it-a-long-mile outfit idea that you've always wanted?
That doesn't spoil anything you might have coming up, I guess.
I don't know.
I guess I always liked military outfits.
Yeah, military outfits are always cool because you always look really cool.
So that's one thing I would love to have in the future.
I have no plans for a military outfit right now, but something I definitely want in the future.
I guess definitely a casual outfit, for sure.
A casual military outfit seems to be like...
Honestly, I feel like every VTuber always has either a military or casual outfit as a checklist for VTubers.
And then everything else is just bonus.
But yeah, most likely those two would be something I'll get in the future.
But they're not the outfits that are planned for 2025.
Doki, I really love you and I want to ask you a question.
Yeah, this is a Q&A.
Yeah, Q&A.
Will you marry me?
I'll do a backflip for you.
Sorry, did he say that?
I'll do a backflip.
Oh wait, no, don't do a backflip because I might be liable.
Unless the convention has a liability contract, you could do a backflip.
But I don't think they're going to endorse that for me.
Alright, next question.
Hey Doki.
What's your favorite anime?
What's my favorite anime?
Okay, Death Note.
It's honestly the anime that got me into anime.
I am basically the most normie VTuber you could sort of watch.
I always talk about this, but I don't watch a lot of anime.
And when I do, it's most likely one of the top animes that everybody's watching right now.
You gotta watch it.
But even then, I feel like I only watch one anime series a year.
Oh my god, you're such a hypocrite, Doki.
You're an anime girl.
You don't even watch anime.
So instead of watching anime, I watch stuff like Young Sheldon.
Which is an incredibly great show.
It's not like Big Bang Theory, by the way.
It's a great show and I cried at the finale, okay?
So I watch stuff like Young Sheldon.
There's... oh my god, what's that?
There's that new school show.
It's basically like The Office, but at a school.
I think it's elementary.
I think that's what it's called.
But it's also really good.
I saw it and I'm like, what's your favorite anime?
And I'm like, yo, this is my normie shows that I watch.
Like...
And then I watch cartoons like Crapopolis and stuff like that.
Which I was so surprised, apparently.
It's written by the guy who wrote Community and everything.
But anyway, anime!
Death Note's my favorite anime because it actually got me looking into anime.
And also collecting figures and stuff like that.
Because I was like, oh I must have a Death Note nendoroid.
Speaking of nendoroids, let me show you my nendoroid real quick.
Hey guys!
And people who don't know who I am...
I have a nendoroid!
Whoa!
Look at that!
You should totally buy it.
Anyway, show's over.
But anyway, I love Death Note because the concept and the artwork was so cool.
And I've always liked the artist and the author.
I also like Bakuman.
I love Bakuman.
I wish it was more popular.
But it's honestly such a good manga and anime series.
But then as I got older, I realized how stupid Light is.
Because he's supposed to be so freaking smart and everything.
And then when you get older, you're like, oh my god, no, he's just an edgy teenager.
He's just this edgy teenager with a huge ass ego.
Which is like every teenager to be fair.
Every teenager that's like, I'm smarter than you type shit.
And then back then, I was like, oh my god, Light, you're so smart.
But now I'm like, oh no, he's like those edgy teenagers and everything.
Anyway, but yes, Death Note is my favorite anime of all time.
I still love Death Note even though growing up, I realized Light's not as great as I thought he was.
Doki, what would you say the meaning of life is?
Is it 42?
Would it be 42 if I just said the wrong number?
What was that?
Is that from Hitchhiker's Guide of... oh my god, I love that.
I love that movie.
Hitchhiker's Guide of the Galaxy, it's such a great movie.
Oh my god, when did that movie come out?
Sorry, off topic right now.
Just like my streams, we're gonna go off topic.
It has a 60% on Rotten Tomatoes?
It came out in 2005?
Oh my god, that's 20 years ago.
Wait, is it 20?
Oh my god, that's 20.
Hitchhiker's Guide of the Galaxy is 20 years ago, that's crazy.
If you guys never watched it, it's a very good movie.
And honestly, it has like the best opening song I've ever heard.
Alright, next question.
Just to brag against Mint even more, will you please marry me?
I'll support you in all your projects.
Alright, next question.
Hey, what if she can say it's no, right?
So going along with the weird questions, two things.
What's your thought about Fi and Mennie Says Hi?
Okay, okay.
Dude, sometimes like some dragoons should not be allowed to talk.
Yeah, you know, sometimes I think like some dragoons don't deserve rights.
And these...
Anyway, next question.
So Doki, what's your opinion on Jeff the Shark and Marvel Rivals?
Oh my god, no, okay.
I talked about it before on stream, but like, you know like when everyone was like, oh my god, it's gonna be like Overwatch again where people are gonna start up their Patreons again and bring up SFMs again.
It's gonna be the return of SFN animations on Patreon, if you know what I mean.
And so like, you know, the moment when the models got exported, the first thing people made was like, was like trying, it was beating up Jeff the Shark.
And so I was like, the fact that like, the fact that like spite and anger triumphs horniness says a lot about how hated Jeff the Shark is in Marvel Rivals.
It's the fact that was the very first animation you saw from Marvel, like fan-made animation you saw from creators.
And that's when you know, Jaws was right.
We should have listened to what they said.
Alright, next question.
Hi, what's your opinion on mint chocolate?
Mint chocolate?
I like white chocolate more.
Honestly, I heard someone was like, damn it!
What?
It's better chocolate!
People are like, oh, dark chocolate is the healthiest, but that shit tastes like, it tastes terrible.
It's so bitter.
I don't understand.
I like milk chocolate the most.
Yeah, I'm not giving you fan service, by the way.
Hi, Doki.
Before I ask my question, I just want to say that Marvel Rivals is a drug and I'm having withdrawals since I couldn't, I can't play anymore since I flew here.
That was me during the concert, don't worry.
Anyways, my question is, when you have free time to watch other content creators and VTubers, what do you usually look for in them?
And who do you watch?
Oh, my God.
Okay, well, like, okay, so, um, like, you all know I have a problem.
So like now I basically all I do is just watch Marvel Rivals streams.
I watch like top high competitive Marvel Rivals streams.
So I literally watch like I fall asleep to Marvel Rivals, and I watch Marvel Rivals on my free time.
And I'm not watching Marvel Rivals.
I'm playing Marvel Rivals.
So this is a problem for me right now.
But like, I guess like other streams I watch.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, let me look.
Oh, that's really, oh, my gosh.
Because like, instead of watching streams, I just watch shows, TV shows instead, or YouTube videos.
Because like, I have, I don't have ADHD, but I do have a very short attention span.
So I can't sit too long watching like a stream sometimes.
So I like to watch like, you know, short porn content, like, I am addicted to shorts as well.
So like, I would just browse YouTube shorts, and like learn so many fun facts and like, or lies on the internet, because some of these YouTube short facts are actual lies.
And then I would regurgitate the lies to you guys and be like, Oh, my God, I heard about this cool, true, very true fact, guys.
But like, yeah, it's usually it.
Like, I guess I would watch like streams from my friends too.
So like, collab with and stuff like that.
And just like comment in their channels and stuff like that.
So usually, other than like, my friends stuff, I just usually just watch like short form content on YouTube, or like Marvel Rivals, because that's a problem.
Hello, there's a lot of new games announced recently.
Are there any upcoming Marvel Rivals that you're excited to play on screen?
Okay, um, oh my gosh, that Pac-Man game.
No, okay, that Pac-Man game is like, it's like what it's apparently some like edgy heart like Pac-Man game where they reimagined the entire series, which is pretty like when I saw the trailer, I was like, I was just like, where's Pac-Man in this Pac-Man game?
And then I was making fun of that was an anthology series where they're like, because we all made fun of the trailer for the anthology series of Pac-Man, not knowing that was just a teaser for an actual video game.
Because I was like, where did they get this idea?
You saw I was like, oh my god, it's gonna be a real game.
Honestly, like all the other okay, I want to know, I want to know what the hell is up with the cat AI game.
Because like, not quote unquote excited, but like, obviously, they must have paid millions of dollars to like get on the Game Awards, because it was apparently like very AI.
And then but then like the fact that they're releasing it on Steam, and Apple Watch is the most crazy combination of game releases.
Like, I was like, what, why is it on the Apple Watch of all things?
Like, what am I gonna do with this cat on my Apple Watch?
I assume it's like something where you bring your AI cat around with you if it's on the goddamn Apple Watch.
Um, but yeah, no, those two games I'm the most excited about one is gonna be a train wreck, which I'm excited to see how that's gonna come up.
And then the other one is just what what the hell is gonna the pacman game is just very interesting concept.
So that's definitely something I'm interested in.
Other than that, I think that's really it.
Any other questions?
See people.
Hello.
Hi, if there were a game of the Sajam Slam did besides Tekken or Street Fighter, what game would you want to play if you were to enter again?
Oh, my.
I was thinking like, I don't know a lot about street like not sure.
I don't know a lot about like, different types of fighting games and stuff like that.
It's like obviously Tekken and Street Fighter are like the classics, but like the two that I really would love to see implemented is okay, the first one would be obviously Mortal Kombat because like, that's a classic and I want to be I want to be a Homelander.
Just for the finisher.
Because the fact that like, if it was ever a Sajam Slam game, tournament game, and I was Homelander, I would 100% hardcore train just so I can use the Homelander finisher, and then have Sajam watch that every time.
Have like, 20,000 people see that every single match.
For those who don't know what the Homelander finisher is, it's basically, he drinks milk, but if you understand the show, you know where the milk comes from.
So, that's why I really would love it.
The second one would actually be Them's Fighting Herds, just because I've always, I remember like following the progress of that fighting game because it was, it used to be like a My Little Pony fighting game, and Hasbro was like, what the hell are you doing?
So it got, but like Lauren Frost, I always loved Lauren Frost's work, because I always loved her art style and like the stuff she does.
For those who don't know who Lauren Frost is, she was the creator of the My Little Pony show for that generation, and she made like other, she also helped out on Powerpuff Girls, and she's married to the guy that made Dexter's Laboratory in Powerpuff Girls.
So like, I thought that was really interesting.
She's married, she's getting married to the guy who made Powerpuff Girls.
And I always loved her stuff, and like, you know, she was like really, she was also like, what the hell, Hasbro?
So she redesigned all the concepts and the characters for that fan-made fighting game, My Little Pony fighting game, and then it became an actual fighting game called Them's Fighting Herds.
So I would love to see that too, because apparently it's a really good fighting game, with the animation and everything.
So I thought it was really interesting.
Okay, next question.
Hey Doki, what's your like go-to food when you're traveling or away from home?
Like for me, if I'm traveling to Japan, I have to eat an egg sandwich at least once a day.
Oh, honestly, true though.
I love Japanese egg sandwiches.
It's because you're made with the, what was it called?
The special mayonnaise sauce?
I forgot.
It's like, the one with the baby on it.
The one with the baby on the bottom.
That's why.
Oh, Kewpie.
Yeah, Kewpie mayonnaise.
That's why it makes it so good.
Honestly, it depends on the country I'm going to.
Honestly, like whenever I travel to a place, it wouldn't be like comfort food, but I would at least once go to a Michelin star restaurant for a new place I'm at.
Because I always want to be like, I'm at a new area.
So for those who don't know what Michelin star restaurants are, they're basically the most bougie as hell place to be.
But I'm like, I'm at a new area.
I'm in a new country.
And I can try it once.
So I was like, oh my gosh, this is my one time I get to splurge a little bit.
And like, honestly, like the only thing I splurge on is like artist alley at conventions, and like food, because like, gotta treat yourself.
So like, I always try to do like a Michelin star restaurant.
Also, like, make sure you read what they serve.
Because in Japan, I went to a Michelin star restaurant in Japan, and I didn't realize like 90% of the meals that they serve was like mushrooms.
And I hate mushrooms.
So I was like, I think I paid like 200 plus dollars, like American dollar, you convert it to like 200 plus dollars for food I can't even like eat and enjoy.
And then they're like, wow.
And you know, like, you know, when you're at a nice restaurant, they'll come over and be like, Oh, did you enjoy your food?
And obviously I lied.
So I'm like, I don't want to be like, no, I hate it.
You don't want to like be rude in Japan.
So I'm like, Oh my gosh, no, it was amazing.
And inside, I'm just like, I kept the 200 dollars.
Um,
but yeah, I don't really have like, a specific comfort food in mind.
Um, it's just mostly I just go to a nice place at least once during my travels.
Doki, since you did a FNAF song at ALA, will you do FNAF karaoke or any other horror song karaoke?
Is there actually more songs?
I feel like the only FNAF song I know is the original FNAF song.
Honestly, like, I don't know.
The other ones I know are like, not, I mean, to be fair, The Living Tombstones was like, the FNAF from The Living Tombstone is a fan song for FNAF.
But like, other than that, I think like, that's like the most famous one.
And also the only one I know.
The other ones I know are like, the Bendy and the Ink Machine.
I know so many Bendy and the Ink Machine fan songs.
Because I wasn't a FNAF girl.
I was more of a Bendy girl.
That sounds so messed up out of context.
But I preferred, back when, like, it was, you know, back when the mascot horror genre was a thing, I never got into FNAF because I hate animatronics.
Like, I have an immense fear of animatronics.
I can't even do, like, It's a Small World because in my head, I'm like, what if there's so many tiny-ass animatronics?
And I'm like, wouldn't they just come alive and just kill me?
Like, I don't know.
I'm just like, oh my god, like, what if just suddenly I'm on this boat and they just lock them alive?
Like, I cannot do animatronics because I have such an immense fear.
So I never played FNAF until, like, I guess, like, a year ago I played it.
And like, so I never really got into FNAF.
And then like, I know people are like, what about the Zora FNAF?
Like, okay, we all know Scott was making shit up as he went along.
So like, I never really cared.
But like Bendy, Bendy actually had, like, really good lore.
And like, I was an animation, like, cartoon freak.
So like, I really, like, related more to Bendy and the Ink Machine than I did with FNAF.
You know, I know FNAF is like, more popular and like, oh my god, is that the fight of 87?
Or is it 97?
Or is it 45?
I really lost track.
There were too many numbers.
And next question.
Hi, Doki, really important question.
Is water wet?
All right.
I mean, I hope I assumed.
Wait, how is that?
Oh my god, am I too stupid to understand like how it's not wet?
Like, I'd say yes, it's wet.
Water is wet.
I don't know how it could be debated against.
Am I just done?
All right, next question.
All right, we have about time for one more good question.
Oh my god, it's been an hour already?
Wow.
Hi,
Doki, I have the most important question of all.
You can only have one of the two infinite, infinite bacon, but no more games or infinite games, but no games.
What?
Infinite games, but no games?
Oh, is it like, oh, it's like a Humble Bundle type deal where you buy the Humble Bundle and you play none of the games.
Like, um, well, like none of them has has gaming as an option, but like the other one has bacon.
So it's like, do you want something or do you want nothing?
So I guess I choose bacon because like, why would I want infinite games if I can't even all the games are like dog shit?
What am I going to do?
Might as well just just watch a stream and live my life through that person then.
On the other hand, I get bacon and I can eat bacon and watch people stream.
So that's that's I can't believe that's the question we're ending on for this panel.
That's my final answer.
You could probably squeeze in one more.
Q&A guy was like, that question was pretty bad.
Let's get another one in.
All
right, the final question, your question is going to end this entire panel better be a really good one.
There's really high expectations.
This is a really good question.
Hey, Doki, so since at the concert, you played Marble Rivals in the concert, does that mean you're going to play a game here?
Why not?
Wait, am I allowed to?
Oh, wait.
I don't know if you guys can hear sound though from this.
It follows my chat microphone.
I mean, okay, I'm down.
All right, I can squeeze again.
Okay, I'm not doing like I'm not losing my GM in front of all of you.
I'm not doing that in front of all of you guys.
Let's see.
All right.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
I hope that I can actually put up Marble Rivals because like I didn't restart my PC and like there is a 50% chance that I would my game would crash.
Oh, my gosh.
Is it on?
Why is it on?
Oh, yeah.
Because I had a sponsor.
I was like, why is it on?
Singularity?
I was like, oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
She's actually doing it.
She's doing it.
All right.
I don't think you guys can.
I don't know if you guys can hear the game sound because like I said, the microphone, the audio is on my microphone, not on my game.
You're gonna watch me play without sound.
You don't need sound.
I'll make sound effects for you guys.
All right, Doki.
You might see next to me here that there's a guy with a little ring camera.
And we're about to see it.
It's about to get zoomed into.
And I believe this is the same one that was at the concert.
Oh, my God.
Really?
It's you.
All right.
Here we go.
I was actually like, I didn't know it was like, oh, my God.
It's InstaQ.
Thank God.
There's too many people.
Oh, it's Ka, King of the Hill.
All right.
I mean, this is, oh, I'm feeling, this is gonna be a quick game.
I'm feeling.
Not Luna Snow?
Oh, my God.
Guys, I'm here to carry.
I don't trust play.
I don't trust quick play players.
There's no, like, skill-based matchmaking in quick play, which is crazy because I can literally, I can solo carry as Luna in quick play, which is crazy to think about.
You gotta give us the sound effects.
I'm not hearing any sound effects.
Okay.
I just realized my own sound was off, too.
All right.
Look at that.
Goodbye.
Oh, my God.
He has a Hawkeye.
I've never seen a Hawkeye in 20 years.
It's always bad.
By the way, they made it so that, oh, we're spawn camping them.
I don't even have to exist.
Oh, no, we're not spawn camping them.
We are not spawn camping them anymore.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Oh, please.
This is not fair.
I haven't seen Hawkeye in 20 years.
He's always bad in rank.
Nobody likes to play against Hawkeye.
All right.
I'm running.
She's jumping and I'm running.
All right, let's go.
There's no way we lose this.
We have a Fister.
I need the audience to get hyped when she gets a build.
I need the audience to get upset when she gets a build.
Oh, you think you're gonna go invisible?
She went invisible, guys.
She did go invisible.
I DPS now.
Oh, you're gonna do this again?
Get over here.
I know where you're going.
That's right.
Easy.
That's how you play Mantis.
You don't care about your team.
You DPS.
I actually need to learn Mantis headshots more.
All right.
All right, we'll do our favorite.
We'll do Jeff.
Wait, is this a good map?
I don't even know if this is a good map for Jeff.
Oh, well.
I never play Jeff because he's bad.
He's bad in rank.
But like, this is quick play.
And we all hate Jeff here.
All right.
Yay!
Wait, do we actually have tank?
Oh my God.
We actually have like a person that's really willing to play tank.
That's crazy.
I think one thing I like about Jeff is that he sings a little song when you're swimming.
He's like, He's like copyright-free Jaws theme song.
I love that we put so much work to bring you out here, and you end up playing Marble Rivals again.
I know, I'm gonna play Marble Rivals rank after.
This is my warm-up before my actual...
All right.
What is she doing?
Oh, that's what she's...
God, I hate Hawkeye.
I hate him so much.
Yet, this person cannot play Hawkeye in actual rank.
So he has to live vicariously in quick play.
No one ever lets people play Hawkeye.
And for a good reason.
I actually sort of low-key forgot how to play Jeff.
I was like, what do I have?
What's my utility?
No one plays Jeff.
Oh, no, no, no, please, please, keep me awake.
No!
You know, Jeff is dog shit.
I hate him.
Wait, no, no, wait, wait.
I gotta use my ult, though.
I'm almost at ult.
And then I'll carry.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I figured it out.
I'll actually help...
Alright.
Get over here.
Whoa!
No!
The shootout!
It's quick play!
You actually shoot the...
People in rank don't even shoot the shark.
Hahahahaha!
Nobody shoots a goddamn shark in rank!
And you do it in quick play?!
Okay.
I'm fine.
Now I actually will play the game.
Alright, that's fine.
Sleep!
Oh, he's not sleeping.
Okay.
Go!
Go do your thing!
Now we have three supports, but that's okay.
I'm my own DPS.
Oh, that's not okay!
I am so sorry.
I almost killed the crew.
Come on!
Guys, I know this looks bad.
Guys, this is why this is my warm-up.
I'm low-key through on Jeff, but like, it'll be different now.
It'll be different next game.
Next round, we'll win this.
We'll win this next round.
You're like, we can squeeze one game in with Lillian and Coff.
This is actually the shortest one too.
Like, if we did like an attack or a defense, that would take forever.
That would actually take forever.
All right, don't worry, guys.
I can carry this.
I swear to God.
I had time to queue one game.
Oh yeah, there's an event!
I forgot.
Little do they know, I'm streaming this at a convention right now too.
Left a negative review on Steam for this event.
Damn, that's messed up.
Oh, team will take this game way too soon.
This is...
If you queue, snipe the streamers.
Oh yeah, the free skins.
All right, go do your thing, little guy.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, this hot guy is actually a problem.
It's such a problem.
I forget how to play against him because you never get a chance to play against him.
All right, okay, this time.
Now that I know... what the fuck?
Oh no, no, he got... there we go.
Oh my god, you have an orb.
That's not fair.
You actually have orbs to make sure you live.
Where is my team?
Are they okay?
Are they... god, you actually have teammates.
Guys, this ain't looking good.
I was very confident now, but like, I don't know why they decided to lock in.
I don't know why they decided to lock in.
I might need to bring out the main now.
Oh no, not the hot guy.
I don't want to look at him.
He's actually good.
Okay.
Oh my god, there's a problem with you.
There is a problem with you.
Get out.
Oh, he's gonna group.
He is 100% gonna group.
Please, where's my cloak?
Cloak, where did you go?
I thought he was with me.
You ran away?
Support and strong together.
Oh my god, I thought we were friends.
Now I know I'll never heal this other support again.
All right, maybe we'll have a good Hawkeye too.
Oh, goodbye.
He's dead.
This is why I want to cut all trees down too.
Okay, oh, oh, okay.
He's, he's just gonna block me.
That's fine.
Okay, guys, we might have lost, but it's not my fault.
I, I did the best I could in the situation I was in.
Oh my god, how do I have more damage than our Hawkeye?
I told you he's a problem.
11k damage and our Hawkeye has 4k.
I told you guys, this is not my fault.
I literally failed and I was able to pull off more damage than our Hawkeye.
All right, and this is why Marble Rivals is a bad for you, because I would have queued another one if I could.
All right, Doki, any last words?
Any last words?
Um, buy my merch.
All right, guys, make some noise for Doki.
Yeah,
I'll thank you again.
I was, I had a great time at the panel.
It's really great meeting all my Dragoons, as always.
Hope you guys enjoy holiday Matsuri.
Bye.
All right, guys, um, another jank stream.
Uh, go to Hawkeye.
Hawkeye Shilling.
Shilling for Hawkeye.
Go to Hawkeye.
Thank you, Oshie Oasis.
All right, ending stream.